time southern about a health district
now releasing details about an in-depth
analysis on the community's needs and
strengths when it comes to improving our
health christian in the studio tonight
with what they found and also what their
next step is kristin well denise this is
great information here it's called the
community health assessment or cha where
the focus is to improve community health
right here in the valley now these zip
codes that you see right here well they
were considered on having the highest
health burdens take a look here it's
we're talking about eight nine one one
five eight nine zero three zero and also
down here eight nine one oh six eight
nine one oh one and finally down here
eight nine one six nine now today i
talked to one of uh someone that was
working on this project and she said
that there's tons of great information
she was also talking about when they
mentioned the community strengths and
assessment they also talked a lot about
the areas of technology and legislation
but she also mentioned that when they
started looking into the public health
system the number one issue that the
folks in the community brought up was
mental health they say that there's a
lack of service in the community
information available to the public
again tons of information that was all
gathered together within a year now
health officials focused on people
experiencing homelessness the lgbt
community
parents of young children the older
population spanish-speaking people and
finally the african-american community
remember this helps county health
officials get an overall view of the
health needs currently in the community
areas of concern were unemployment
education transportation and violence
the participants were really talking
about how
availability to care is not the same as
accessibility um so this really goes
into the cost versus access and
individuals in these groups really
talked about how there's low quality
health care in addition to mistrust
so
these participants in all of these
groups really acknowledge that there are
services and programs that exist within
the community
but without that access to reliable
transportation
well this is an annual report that
started back in 2016. now this year's
report is designed to help communities
right here in southern nevada improve
their public health status over the next
five years now you may be asking what
comes next well the hope is to start
working on an improvement plan which
will be happening in october you can
read the full report on our website
right now eight newsnow dot com
christian cassette is eight news now